honey and agave are the healthiest
alternatives to sugar the funny part of
that is honey is sugar you should cut
all sugar from your diet let's not do
that high fructose corn syrup is the
worst kind of sugar we can't really say
that it's any better or any worse hi my
name is mary matone i'm a registered
dietitian and i primarily work with
clients with type 1 type 2 diabetes as
well as heart disease my name is
meredith rothhart i'm a registered
dietitian and i work with people who are
interested in overall wellness and
weight management and weight loss and
today we'll be debunking myths about
sugar sugar is bad for you so that's a
bold statement and i would say that that
is false the body does need sugar when
you eat anything that does contain sugar
or sugar compounds
in the body everything does get
converted to glucose and that's
ultimately what our body uses as main
energy source specifically the brain it
just comes down to what kind of sugar we
need more often and what kind of sugar
we should be limiting most of the time
natural sugar is coming from whole foods
like fruits and vegetables and whole
grains and legumes and then you have
your simpler sugars more refined and
more processed like candy and packaged
baked goods that have been basically
extracted from your whole foods to be
converted to their simplest form they're
not nutrient dense there's no nutrients
attached of your total daily calories
less than 10 should be coming from added
sugars high fructose corn syrup is the
worst kind of sugar a food that has high
fructose corn syrup isn't necessarily
any worse than a food that has regular
table sugar in terms of comparing this
to the sugar that you might find in
fruit which is also fructose it's
probably worse for you but when
comparing it to other sugars that have
been extracted from whole foods we can't
really say that it's any better or any
worse what's most important probably in
this case is how much you're consuming
of it a high intake of these foods
can cause elevated blood sugar over time
it can also lead to more cravings for
sugar less feelings of satiety what it's
also doing is taking away room for whole
foods that do have these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals we do need daily
if you do have limited access to food
and you are able to find things such as
frozen or even canned vegetables canned
beans canned fish these can be good
options to help balance out that sugar
intake if it is accessible honey and
agave are the healthiest alternatives to
sugar we hear all the time if you want
to cut sugar instead of using sugar use
honey the funny part of that is honey is
sugar honey and agave are commonly
thought to be better sugars because they
contain antimicrobial or antioxidant
properties but you'd have to eat so much
to really reap those benefits so let's
say you're baking a banana bread or
pumpkin pie do you need to swap all of
your table sugar in your baking recipes
for honey no you can stick to the
regular sugar and it's going to have
pretty much the same outcome as if you
swapped it with honey what it really is
coming down to is how much are you
consuming too much honey too much agave
too much table sugar all going to have
negative health consumption oh too much
sugar sugar makes you hyper sugar gives
you energy that's its job that is not
the same thing as hyperactivity what is
hyperactivity it is a feeling of short
attention span inability to concentrate
for long periods of time all the studies
done on sugar and hyperactivity and
related diseases like adhd conclude that
sugar does not make you hyper you can
even make the opposing argument that
sugar drains you that might lead to that
feeling of what we call a sugar crash
feelings of fatigue tiredness being
sluggish a couple hours after a meal
when people say i'm hangry that is that
feeling of a sugar crash if you want to
avoid that sugar crash later in the day
give yourself some energy in the morning
from sugar but make sure you're pairing
it with fiber protein and healthy fats
and make sure you don't go too long
without eating you should cut all sugar
from your diet let's not do that not
only is it not really recommended it
would be really hard to do like we
mentioned earlier it is literally the
form of energy for our bodies let's say
you fully cut out all sugar in some way
but no longer has sugar to use for
energy your body then starts to produce
ketone bodies from fat to then be used
as energy although in the beginning of
this process this might feel okay in
your body over time this is not going to
be beneficial for your cells for weight
management for blood sugar control that
does have a cascading and domino effect
on things like inflammation and hormones
so it's not smart or beneficial to cut
all sugar from the diet when you're
depriving the brain of its main energy
source it's natural to then start
feeling things like brain fog fatigue
cognitive decline artificial sweeteners
are healthier than sugar this is
technically a myth so let's say you're
having your morning cup of coffee and
you normally put a tablespoon of sugar
in is putting artificial sweetener in
like sweet and low or splenda better for
you
not necessarily if your goal is to
minimize calories yeah artificial
sweeteners could be a good option they
are 200 to 20 000 times sweeter than
sugar it could in some cases be a better
alternative for someone with diabetes
that being said if you notice over time
that artificial sweeteners are making
you hungrier later in the day i would
consider changing it up one possible
issue that studies have found is that
long-term use or high amount of
artificial sweetener might have an
effect on your hunger hormones and your
fullness hormones this could lead to
overeating also because it's so much
sweeter it might affect your taste next
time you go to eat something with
regular sugar it might not taste as
sweet to you and you might want more to
get that same level of sweetness
sugar is only in sweet foods this is
also false sugar is a basic molecule in
anything from fruit to starch to bread
to pasta to beans sauces dressings and
gravies so when you're having french
fries and ketchup you're not really
thinking that you're having sugar but
it's in there if you want to look out
for other foods that don't naturally
contain sugar it's always important to
check the nutrition facts label scan
down to total carbohydrates and under
that you'll see sugars and added sugars
try to watch out for too many grams of
added sugars on the label ideally it's
recommended to consume less than six
teaspoons from added sugar daily
sugar is addictive no sugar is not
addictive addiction is a chronic or
compulsive physiological or
psychological need for a habit-forming
substance and not having that substance
will cause withdrawal sugar does not
have that same habit-forming addictive
qualities you do get some pleasure and
reward when you have sugar because it
triggers dopamine which is a
neurotransmitter in the brain
responsible for that feeling of
happiness and pleasure and reward which
might make you feel more inclined to
choose it again and you might crave it
for that reason but it is not the same
thing as addiction there's a lot of
reasons that we crave sugar if you're
eating something like candy and it's not
paired with anything like fiber healthy
fat or protein there's not enough other
food or nutrients there to help slow the
uptake or the digestion and absorption
of sugar and what happens is then your
blood sugar drops a lot earlier and now
you're hungrier your brain wants to
bring that blood sugar back up to
baseline and your brain knows the
quickest thing to do that is a
carbohydrate and sugar
sugar causes diabetes no sugar itself
does not cause diabetes so diabetes is a
condition in which your body isn't
properly processing blood sugar there's
two types of diabetes type 1 diabetes is
an autoimmune disease which in its
pathology has nothing to do with what
you're eating type 2 diabetes is caused
by a number of factors which include
overweight obesity lifestyle factors
exercise genetics these also play a role
what we can say is high intake of
refined sugars especially if they're not
paired with other nutrients properly and
are causing that erratic blood sugar we
discussed earlier we can say that that
likely contributes to diabetes but to
say that eating sugar will give you
diabetes is false
people with diabetes can't eat sugar
big false
big problem with saying people with
diabetes can't eat sugar is that when
people with diabetes don't actually get
enough sugar and their blood sugar drops
too low
that can be a big diabetic emergency and
even falling into a diabetic coma people
with diabetes just have to be a lot more
careful and strategic let's say you want
to have a piece of fruit in the morning
i wouldn't pair it with a sugary cereal
i would try to pair it with something
that's going to be a little bit more
balanced maybe like an omelet an
omelette is going to have eggs which is
going to give you some fat and protein
and maybe even top it with avocado for a
little bit more fat we need to think
about when we're having sugar and what
we're pairing it with so it's not
causing that rapid blood sugar spike
sugar is a part of a balanced diet the
main things are that you understand what
sugar is doing in your body know how to
effectively pair sugar with fat and
protein and when it comes to added
sugars or processed packaged foods
moderation is key